because i always feel like
with the homeless thing there's there's
like you said there's people who
are there because they don't have a
choice so they want to get out of it
they want to get right into a better
place and then there are a fraction of
the people who have drug problems who
have mental problems right who
you know
not even talking about the people who
just want to be liberated from society
but people who just
are in a position where
they might have addiction that they're
dealing with
um
do you feel like
like what do you think is the solution
for those people psychedelics
just give everyone some shrooms some
ayahuasca
not just give it to them and say here
take this but
you know something that i want to create
is i want to i want to create an
environment
where people going through addiction and
trauma
can be inducted into a program
where their diet is all raw fruits raw
vegetables
and they micro dose shrooms and
dmt and ayahuasca
and they go on an inward journey into
their psyche and i believe that you can
help cure
a lot a lot yeah
i think ayahuasca is like the one thing
that like i know people who have had um
lifelong addiction yeah they've had
vices that they could never shake
they've had
suppressed mental stuff that they never
even knew was the reason why they were a
certain way yeah because it forces you
to like have you done ayahuasca yeah
yeah
and when i've i
for me everyone's experiences did you do
it with a
shaman shaman yeah yeah yeah
um
i'm a shaman
are you yeah well no
yeah okay
um but uh you're an ayahuasca shaman i'm
just a shaman in general ninja in life i
respect that okay yeah
but um
these drugs
are not these these met this medicine i
don't even want to call it a drug but
it helps you look at yourself this
character that you created for yourself
and
for me i looked at all the things that
made me me and
i don't know man it's just
when i took dmt for the first time i
seen these little elves these mechanical
elves they were just like laughing at me
i was like in this whole like mechanical
realm and they were just like laughing
and
it made me feel like
in this other dimension somewhere
there's people they're just laughing at
us because we're just [ __ ]
trivial yeah we're just so trivial we're
like working our whole lives at jobs we
[ __ ] hate to buy [ __ ] we don't need
and yeah [ __ ] impress people yeah
yeah and just like in fear and [ __ ] and
they're just like
like you know like life is so [ __ ]
simple
it really is man and
you know i i wear nice [ __ ]
not because i feel like it brings my
value up or to get girls or to look cool
but i genuinely
um i love
i'm a fan of aesthetics you know i love
nice [ __ ]
but it doesn't define me man i've got
i'll give i give [ __ ] away i don't give
a [ __ ] you know
yeah um what for when you did ayahuasca
how did that like what was that
experience like for you because you know
sometimes people puke they [ __ ] they're
[ __ ] i mean it's for people who who
don't know it's like a process it's not
like you just you get the shivers you
get the shakes you i mean it's like d
it's like detoxing it's like when you're
going through a uh what you call it a
heroin withdrawals and [ __ ] you know
um
[Music]
i i've heard people say that like
there's like a voice you hear
or like are you going to the astral
plane you're floating in nothingness
you're going through a black hole i mean
me i don't know what anyone else is
going but
your time stops it just
there is no time there is no nothing
you're like one with everything
that's crazy and you know obviously for
people who don't know it's it's like
something you drink you know i don't
think i think people for the most part
probably know about shrooms they
probably know about dmc i think
ayahuasca is the one thing that's like
not as easily as accessible
i think it might be it's pretty in the
future i think it's going to be
something more people tap into but
can you imagine that creating some type
of process on skid row where people
where people are introducing these yeah
because i do think that that is a way
that people can really kick real
addiction yeah yeah you know it's like
addiction is like especially the
certain [ __ ] is like
physically
hard just to just just to do because you
know if i quit doing this
then i got a week of the worst pain in
my life coming my way so i'm just going
to keep doing it yeah and there's no
like
i guess you know i think that that's
probably
one of the bigger reasons why like
people end up homeless
like it is what it is like you know
being a drug addict is a full-time job
they say being an addict to anything is
a full-time job yeah you treat it like
it's like your job every day to get high
or to
whatever whatever that thing is yeah i
um
yeah i agree